now but even Biden himself would say
that he's like a bridge he's like a
bridge president to go from like this
one era to another and so he even knows
his place like in this you know and I
don't know if he's going to run again
he's already campaigning I guess but
it's like do does his own party even
want him to run again Joe Biden will
never run again he's too old I made that
joke twice I think he's gonna try it
maybe he'll run I hope he's got
to print it up the stairs himself that's
what I'm saying I think they inject him
with stuff right before he's going to be
his IV oh yeah he held up his hands and
you can track mark track marks yeah no
they they pump that man full of uh
plenty of goofballs yeah
they put him in as a placeholder knowing
he won't Squawk on the liberal economic
order because his son is so deeply
involved with barisma and with China and
he himself has been so involved with it
dude he was stealing is this considered
stealing classified documents if you
walk out of there as the vice president
and take him well the the reason why you
know Biden is a perfect puppet is
because there's so much dirt on him